Hey this is Presh Talwalkar
Think of a two digit number
Add up the digits of the number together
Subtract your result from your original number
I want you to focus on this number
I'll call this your
magic number
In the following table locate your magic number
and concentrate on the symbol next to your number
If you have the number 4 for example
I want you to concentrate on the symbol of the person on the motorcycle.
Are you concentrating on your symbol?
Alright, I'm going to try and read your mind now.
You're looking at the symbol of an eye.
Did I get it correct?
If you followed the directions correctly I did make the correct prediction.
Why is this?
Let's go through the steps
A two digit number can be represented by a binomial 10 X plus y
When you add up the digits of the number that becomes the number X plus y
If you subtract the sum of the digits from the original number
the Y's will cancel out so you have 10 X minus X which is equal to 9 X
I don't know what your original
number is. I don't know what the sum of your digits are
but I know your magic
number will be a multiple of 9
In the table there will always be the same symbol for the multiples of 9 and that's the eye.
Thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel
I make videos on math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at Presh Talwalkar and if you like this video please check out my books
their links in the video description.